siccome ragazzi ci eravamo veramente
divertiti nel primo episodio di scrive
punto io oggi con email
facciamo l'episodio numero due se quello
era stato esilarante questo non avete
idea buona visione
lexus e con e facci sognare fatto
[Musica]
perfetto faccio una cosa legata con
animazione cosa legata a quello che ha
fatto sasha verità vuvuzela trombetta è
la più remore
germano moscova a mano mosca la verde è
vero ma la scritta in russia il quadro
cile nel rettangolo in rosso ma cosa
diavolo è questo che non è proprio non è
facile è una cagata
no non è una cagata dai lega madonna
ragazzata cos'è sta roba
ma dai come se la cava match ma ragazzi
abbiamo capito che cos'è colpe di
giuseppe riina non so è un verbo non è
un verbo ce l ha con il gioco è un po
daiana golf sia chi no capitolone credo
molto in alto
non lo so ne andai
è sempre quello più versione piccola
a dirlo è capitolata reti stupida
qualcosa ne possibile madonna michael
grande sociale necessaria sussurri
finisce conti e felice no non si capisce
è felice cosa fa se è felice e sta
morendo sì ma sembra che sta esplodendo
mamma felice con quei capelli di merda è
effettivamente non è possibile ma io ho
scritto l'altra parola ho scritto ma
ecco perché non mi veniva con un occhio
hanno preso anche la ypsilon tacchio era
rimasto dall'inter arriva streghe o chi
sbaglia ma li vedete gli spazi sopra
siete fottutamente c'è chi no no questa
è l'amico ragazze queste l'amico l'amico
l'amico a
proprio lui subita di casa sono stati
fermati a freddie l'amico di questo
questo o quell'amico che incassa disegni
l'amico è un topolino e l'altro
comperino come il segno velocemente
foligno famosi che ci divertiamo quello
che nella vita
nell'inizio anch'io forma detta dove un
pigiama ghetto cos'è sta roba
ricevo la d maiuscola o cazzola chi è la
chiesa vuol dire che non so per bene poi
come ai sud ha cosa vuol dire oh cazzo
la chiesa all'occhio è presentato
davanti a lui dagli occhi di gente a
piedi fuoco la baguette ma hai creato un
marito di gomma ma io so
finisce con hicks cosa potreste
centrando su di lei
lei era lui
si chiama fernando lo dico io l'ho fatto
io
oddio oddio ma non può iscrivere cifra
di 3 p 8 non so come cosa sono c3 di
otto dai ragazzi non chi lo guarda già a
bada vadano cciss chinato e ci sei quasi
dark waters più o meno da vedere ok non
so come cazzo si scrive da mother padre
ma del fare
siamo tornati puglia naga draghi è
facilissimo ma cosa da questo è facile
policnico e quelli che amo però hai
fatto [ __ ] pagava qualche non a
valutare ora l'ultima attenzione può
sembrare suri solo con una che battaglia
pazzesca ma perché queste bacche rosa
non mi rompere malato è un fatto né
cannato
wi fi in faccia
6 cosenza ho vinto su yepes herpes per
questo un gatto infatti allergy credo
grattini gatti tiffany frattini va bene
oddio ho forti finanziamento è beccata
scritto sbagliato maggio full multi jet
stream arrivato qua non me la sto giro
dai bellissima però bella mi piacevo da
signori e questi erano gli episodi
scrivo punto l'ho io che abbiamo fatto
sul canale è più quello di tecnica
uscito sul suo ci vediamo al prossimo
video sempre coi mezzi settimana
prossima martedì è anche quello sarà una
bomba ve lo prometto per adesso
iscrivetevi a canale schiacciate mi
piace eroi come sempre da mille anni a
questa parte ci veniamo alle pozioni da
ragazzi
[Musica]